Hi there. I'm Rachel Lee Neighbors, and
today I'm here to talk with you about
how to use local models to stop paying
for frontier models. Let's dig into it.
So, I've worked on standards that power
today's web with Mozilla on Firefox
DevTools and the W3C on web standards,
and of course on Microsoft's Edge
browser. I've even been on the React
team.
Now, I've spent the past 3 years
consulting with AI startups and some of
our favorite LLM and browser companies
on all things web, AI, and UI.
And recently, I've joined Arize. Have
you ever had your CTO ruin your agentic
workflow with a slight change of prompt
or an LLM migration? Have you ever been
that CTO? Well, you probably need
Arize's observability platform for
models and the agents who love them.
Anyway, I'll be actually using one of
Arize's open-source projects today,
Phoenix. We'll talk more about that
later.
But today, specifically, I'm here to
talk with you about how AI is costing
you. Every time you reach for foundation
models like GPT-5 or Claude, it's
costing you, your users, and the
environment.
Let's have a look at the costs of
one-size-fits-all inference.
So, first there's security. Security
costs trust. When you use a large LLM
that's in the cloud, you're sending data
to remote servers, and it always carries
the risk of exposure, interception, and
retention by third parties. We have
cases where the use of remote AI
chatbots has led to sensitive business
data being stored, breached, and leaked
to the public.
Latency costs the user experience. Now,
there's been research on mitigating
response delays in LLM chats in VR and
found that 4 seconds is the limit of
believability for users, and many calls
that you will make to large models are
going to take longer than 4 seconds, as
we will see when we check Phoenix.
It cost your business. Third-party
inference costs are uncontrollable
compared to API
API costs. Agency compounding levels of
inference and this means even if the
tokens are cheaper, you may be using
more of them or if you're using four of
them, they may be more expensive. And of
course, if you aren't connected, remote
models simply aren't going to work,
which means that unless your software is
connected to the web, nobody can use it.
Big inference going offline costs
productivity. If there's an outage, if
you're in a place where you cannot reach
Wi-Fi or you're in a very secure
environment.
Now, token costs have been falling as of
late, but total inference spend has been
rising because agent can reasoning
workloads consume tokens way faster than
prices are dropping.
But we can completely eliminate most of
these costs and it starts by asking
ourselves
exactly how much [snorts]
is this costing? Do we really need an
LLM to do this job?
All right. You can use task-specific
models, which are small in size and
power consumption compared to an AI
foundation. Uh this is my little cheat
sheet. If you're looking for an expert
model, is a camera pointing at
something?
Division uh you know, is is there a a
vision component? You can use a model
like MobileNet, YOLO, MediaPipe. Is it a
microphone recording something? There
are audio models like Whisper and
Wave2Vec2.
Chat translation or analysis? This is
where you might use something like a
small language model like Gemma or
Quinn.
These uh small models are called SLMs
uh
or smaller language models. The the
definition of small is up to debate
here. Uh these are great for times when
we do need the language power of a
generative pre-trained trans-
transformer, a GPT, but we probably
don't need the sum total of human
knowledge in a black box at our
disposal, or we don't need multimodal
capabilities. We're not going to be
analyzing images and audio at the same
time.
Now, SLMs, smaller language models,
contain millions to billions of
parameters.
An LLM contains billions to, well,
trillions. So, you see the big dot
there? That's one of the smaller LLMs
that's out there. But, the little dot
actually represents one of the larger
SLMs. So, you can see that there is a
huge difference in parameter size, and
this means that there is a vast
difference in the size of machine you're
going to need to run one of these
models. The good news is you don't need
most of what's in the the big green dot
there. You don't need history, you don't
need philosophy, you don't need all
those Reddit chats, you don't need a lot
of what the models have learned and been
trained on. Most of us are using our
models for things like summarizing a
chat thread, or detecting if this
person's being a jerk right now. And it
takes a surprisingly
smaller amount of parameters to
determine those things.
Now, the nice thing about smaller
language models is that they consume the
same or less energy as large language
models to produce correct uh awareness.
We have uh correct responses. We have
good good research that shows this.
Small language models um
they come in all sizes and shapes. Most
small language models uh for mobile and
web are deployed with quantization, that
is to say, 8-bit, 4-bit, and that can
have a quarter disk and memory
requirements. 1 billion parameters fits
on about 2 GB in FP16.
Uh
this this grid, by the way, gives upper
bound estimates. So, these are just to
give you an idea of what will and will
not fit on different devices.
These are so lightweight that they can
be put on devices.
Speaking of, my Pixel Pro ships with
one.
And I I of course bought the the Pixel
10 Pro as soon as I could because I
wanted to know what it would be like to
work with an on-device model.
An SLM of my very own.
The good news is that small language
models are production ready. Nvidia
called SLMs the future of agentic AI.
Once again, great research paper from
2025 that found that SLMs are
sufficiently powerful for running
agentic task loads. And they consume
less energy than language models. Let me
Let me give you
a bar chart here to take a peek. So,
let's say this is the total amount of,
you know, energy consumed to perform a
task that an LLM would take. An SLM
takes about 25% of that. And a
task-specific model takes about half of
that over. So, as you can see, it's from
an energy perspective much cheaper to
run the smaller language models and
task-specific models.
Um
So, what are the benefits? Once more,
more secure, works offline, no fees,
more efficient, and lower latency
because it's on device, no round trips.
Now, I've been using
local AI for some time.
I for instance first started using local
models. You see on the left you've got
Claude, but on the right you have Goose,
which is
an open an open agent harness that has a
a really nice interface for chatting
with models. And this one here, it's
running Gemma, and it's able to answer.
It takes a little longer. Smaller models
can be a little longer depending on what
device you're running and how big the
model is. But one of my favorite
questions to ask a model is
how likely is it that ichthyosaurs,
marine reptiles from the dinosaur era,
had echolocation cuz if you look at
their skeletons, they look a lot like
dolphins. And it takes
reasoning about biology to be able to
determine whether or not that's
possible. And it's hilarious to me that
even I think this was Gemma 3 was able
to come up with a good a good response
that there is no evidence in the fossil
record of their having developed a melon
or the specialized bones required for
conduction that dolphins have.
Of course, Claude hedged it by saying,
"Well, we just can't know." Uh about one
out of every three times, which was
interesting. Claude has always been
a little nervous about about coming
forth with an opinion.
So, how do you pick the best model for
the job? This is the hard part. Uh I
recent
I
So, how do you pick the best model for
the job?
I built a framework with Google that I
use on my own projects.
You can find more about it at web.dev,
but I'll run through it here. Now, first
off, I like to think of this as
prototype big, deploy small. Just repeat
this to yourself. Prototype big. Think
big. Go big. Deploy small.
Um
you want to convert the parts of your
system over to SLMs
and specialized models for production,
but you can prototype on a foundation
model, no problem.
Uh the first step in this process is to
determine whether or not what you're
trying to do is even possible at all.
You use the largest, most capable model,
and you you just see if you can get it
to do the thing. See if you can get the
model to recognize people
by their handwriting or the way they
they write. If that is possible, then
you know that another model can probably
handle it, too.
So, you could use like a foundation
model like Gemini, or you could use a
really really tough uh task-specific
model for like handwriting recognition
for instance.
Now, this is a feature of the product
that I like to build on the side. It's
Mima. It is a a client for all your
social networks. And I built a feature
for it that
summarizes long conversation threads.
Because I don't know about you, but
sometimes I go to bed and I wake up and
there's 50 comments on something I
posted.
And I just want to know, are people
angry at me? And this is what uh
this is a feature that saves me saves me
a lot of heart attacks in the morning.
So, I first prototyped it out with
Claude to prove that it's good enough.
So, you can see the little
you can see the little summaries there,
and says a pretty good job of of saying
who's talking about what.
So, first step for this was to collect a
set of inputs and outputs, that is to
say in in my case, I wanted to collect a
set of threads, and then how I would
summarize them. Or in this case, how
Claude summarized them seemed adequate
to me. So, I I exported a golden data
set. Now, a golden data set is a curated
high-quality collection of preferably
human-labeled input-output pairs that
you're going to use as the ground truth
to evaluate, validate, and benchmark
your model.
This is what the the data looked like.
Um this is all public knowledge, but you
know, you can see it's got the author
handle, the content, created at, whether
or not it came from me.
And I created a big JSONL of all of
these. So, there were 14 threads, and I
evaluated each one for summaries and
annotations. Because some of the
summaries actually link deeper to ex
link deeper into the conversation. So,
it was the same threads, but had two
different outcomes for them. One was a
short summary, and one was a summary
with references.
All right. So, that means 28 examples
all together.
Um
yeah. So,
these are the things that I was going to
be measuring. Um you need to before you
start doing anything, you need to know
what it is that you're measuring. What
is success?
In this case,
was the JSON being output by the
summarization process correct? Um an
easy way to test is to try JSON parse.
And if it works, yay. If it doesn't,
boo.
Um the reference structural validity,
you know, if it's pointing to different
parts of the conversation inside the
summary, do those parts actually exist?
Factual consistency, that is to say that
it's actually able to summarize the
content of the threads
within reasonableness. So, if we're
talking about cats, it doesn't give a
summary saying we're talking about
puppies.
Uh this is this is something that we
need an LLM to judge or humans, but the
LLMs will be cheaper, I assure you. Um
length compliance, making sure it stays
within a certain word count, and of
course checking the latency. P50, this
is, you know, the median across the eval
set, and the P95 is the worst-case
scenario. All right.
So, you collect these,
uh
and now you're going to test and do
different models,
and compare
how those models rank against the big
models. You test from small to large.
I had to choose a selection of models,
but first I need to find a framework, a
tool to do the measuring. And I chose
Phoenix, which happens to be created by
Arize. It is open source, it's free and
the engineers who work on it are pretty
darn awesome if I do say so myself.
We're going to perform first of all a
what is known as a capability eval. A
capability eval asks, you know, what can
this agent do well?
Where we compare the performance of the
large model against the performance of a
selection of smaller models. We say this
is what Claude Opus produced and this is
what Gemma 4 produced.
How do these two stack up against each
other?
Now, I used Claude Sonnet for the
baseline. And you can see actually there
in the bottom number one, you can see
the the baseline. It's looking pretty
good. It's got an average latency of 2.9
seconds. It costs about $0.22
$0.22
to run this
to run 14 of these tasks. So, I actually
did some math and it turns out I'm using
about a dollar worth of inference every
day using Mima.
I don't have the money to pay for that
many teenage girls
using Mima every day. So, we're going to
have to run this on device.
Good news is the total cost column for
all these small local models is
absolutely zilch because that inference
has been pushed to the consumer. It runs
on their device. They're the one who has
to charge the phone so that it can draw
energy from the battery to run the
model. Of course, you want it to not
suck suck the battery dry, but that is
another conversation for something that
we could be testing and evaluating in
the future.
Now, I chose Let's look at our Let's
look at our contestants here.
We've got Quen 2.5 Instruct weighing in
at 1.5 billion parameters, only a handy
1 GB on disk, and its sister Quen 3,
1.7 billion, just a little bit bigger.
And Llama 3.2, weighing in at 3 billion
parameters and a tidy 2 GB on disk. And
then there was Gemma 4 E2B, which is 5
billion parameters, a hefty 3.1 GB, but
this was the one that so many engineers
I spoke with when I was picking a model
were like, "Oh, Gemma 4 is the best. You
got to use Gemma 4."
And I think that's important here
because if I had just gone with what my
buddies told me,
I may have given the user What? Pardon.
Not may have. I would have given the
user an extremely different experience,
not a good experience.
You're going to want to select the
smallest model that gives acceptable
responses for your use case. Or as I
like to call it, the SAGE model, the
small and good enough model. I'm trying
to make this a thing. Bear with me. I
hope we can make SAGE happen.
Now, at first, I thought I wanted the
the Qwen 2.5 model because it was the
fastest. You can see that Qwen is all
the way here. Let's see, where'd it go?
Yeah, 2.5 is the gray circle in the
lower left-hand corner. It came in
around 1 second total in latency
on the P
P50. That that's amazing. Like, that's
really fast
for for an AI summary. The problem was
that its accuracy was pretty pretty low
compared to everybody else. The orange
square is Gemma 4 E2B and the blue
diamond is Claude Sonnet, which is our
ceiling. It's the most accurate, but
it's also a little pudgy, a little slow.
It's weighing in around 3 seconds in
latency. So, when we take accuracy into
account, the winner was actually Llama
3.2, which is the big green circle
that's weighing in right here around the
90% for accuracy. And you can see that
both uh both
Claude and uh
and Llama 3.2 are
much faster than Gemma 4. Gemma 4 was
coming in around
8 seconds. Now, maybe that was because
Gemma 4 needed a different kind of
prompt, but this was pretty consistent.
I was testing each one of these three
times and then averaging the results.
This is what the results look like. I
recommend when you're running evals with
something like like like Phoenix, you
open up the experiment and you actually
take a look. You can see what the raw
responses were, uh what the expected
responses were. You can actually compare
them against each other. Um I found that
in many cases, Llama's response was so
close to Claude's response as to be
pretty much indistinguishable from one
another.
So, yeah. Uh Llama 3.2 was the ultimate
winner and I decided to move forward
with them. And this makes sense because
Llama 3.2 is created by Meta and Meta
has a strong interest in creating
models that do a good job with human
inputs and summarizing human things on a
social network. Makes sense, right? I
mean, it's a social thing. Benefits from
a a social model.
So, recap. Here's how you right-size
your model in four steps. Number one,
you prove it's possible. You test
whether what you're trying to accomplish
is possible at all by using the largest
possible model. This could be a
foundation model like Gemini or a
task-specific model.
>> [snorts]
>> And you set success criteria. You
collect a set of inputs and outputs um
that that you want to see
coincide with one another.
This will be the bar.
And then you test from small to large.
You compare the outputs of small models
against your test criteria and you work
your way up from the smallest model
until you you within an acceptable range
of that small and good enough model,
that sage model.
That's when you select your sage model,
the smallest model that gives acceptable
responses for your inputs.
But you're probably wondering, what are
we going to do about that gap? I mean,
90% accuracy, that sounds like it could
be uh you know, that could be a deal
breaker.
Well, we can squeeze better performance
out of smaller models with prompt
engineering. This is important in cases
where you can't control which model
you're using. Some people might, for
instance, create a distilled model
that's been trained to do this one task
really well.
But if you're working, for instance,
with a mobile app, you might not want to
be using a distilled model because every
time you add capabilities, you'll
probably have to train the model
slightly, and then you'll be shipping a
new 1 or 2 GB model every time to your
users. So, this is a great example of
like,
"Ooh, I don't think I'll be able to
control that model. Once it's on the
user's device, I'm not going to ask them
to download new ones. That would eat up
their data plan." Um you might join a
team, and they're already committed to
Gemma 3, and they're just not going to
be implementing Gemma 4 until they've
rolled out an an an update that uh you
know, addresses all of the evals.
So, let's take a look at closing the gap
between Saona and Llama.
Now, the the green and blue dots in that
upper left-hand quadrant.
So, the measures I I honed in on, the
ones that they really seem to have
different results with, were JSON
reference uh JSON and reference
structural validity, factual
consistency, um P50 latency, and P95
latency. And I decided that the P50
latency the cutoff is, you know, one 1
and 1/2 seconds for P95 would be 3 and
1/2 because, remember, 4 seconds is that
worst-case scenario for people feeling
disconnected from an
AI powered experience as per the
research.
So,
where do we start? I recommend that you
optimize one step at a time. You want to
isolate one variable per prompt variant
to test whether what you're trying to
accomplish is
moving the needle when you're using the
different prompts.
So, I created five prompts. Well, I
created four prompts and I had the
original prompt as the baseline. The
original prompt was pretty good. V2 used
number input. The same prompt
reformatted the threat the threat as
numbered messages instead of using JSON.
The hypothesis being that smaller models
could track natural language indexing
better than
array offsets in
heap of JSON.
The second one was a few shot. It added
a couple of examples and outcomes to the
prompt. The hypothesis here being that
small models learn format from examples
faster than from rules.
Then there was the strict rules version.
This one was a house of no prompt. It
had explicit negative constraints. No
preamble. Don't count words before
responding. I mean, do count words
before responding. And the hypothesis
was that small models respond to literal
commands and that they like to be bossed
around a bit. And then lastly, there was
chain of thought which forced the model
to identify key moments before writing.
The hypothesis just being that thinking
out loud would improve grounding.
So, [snorts]
ran the tests again with these new
prompts and just just
just to the llama 3.2 and we discovered
a couple of things.
We I mean, myself.
I just ran this locally on my machine
and was able to compare the results. You
can even put the results into something
like Claude and have have conversation
about the trades if you like. So,
stop that.
All right, we're back.
So, in this case, the baseline
wasn't really good at at the
determining how short it should be so it
would fit within
a certain section of content. The ref
accuracy was 91.2%.
It was factually correct 87.1% of the
time and the latency was 1 second.
Reformatted input didn't really make a
difference.
Explicit rules actually didn't made
things worse.
The model responded very negatively to
being told what it couldn't do couldn't
couldn't do. It um
it was a a naughty child didn't like to
take instructions.
Chain of thought didn't have that big a
it it did a little bit better on the
length
and unfortunately that came at
increasing the latency by 600
milliseconds. The best performing one
was the few shot one that provided a
couple of threads and a couple of
examples. It was much better at getting
the length right. It was more accurate
and
in its references it agreed with the
Claude model a little bit more about
what was said and it only increased the
the latency by 200 milliseconds. So,
that sounds like a pretty good deal,
right?
So, it was the few shot
prompt that one that made the biggest
improvement.
Let's have a look at how it stacks up to
the original.
Bum bum bum. So, you can see the bar
here Claude Sonnet versus Llama 3.2 3B.
Um I actually did a couple of things at
this point because I wanted to close
that gap completely.
So,
Llama 3.2B with a few shot prompt was
actually able to get within a reasonable
error area of um
a reasonable error margin of error. The
P50 latency went to less than 1 and 1/2
minutes, so it was totally green. Uh the
structural validity 91.7%
factual consistency was also at 92.9%
Uh the P95 latency was
well under 750 milliseconds
uh less than Claude. In general, its
latency was really good.
But, let's see about those uh those
couple of those 10% here between
structural validity and factual
consistency. This is why it's important
to actually open up your e-vows and take
a look at what's inside.
Uh when it came to factual consistency,
it turned out that Claude was just being
a very strict judge. I was using Claude
to judge the responses and comparing,
you know, Claude Opus was comparing
Claude Sonnet's response to uh Llama
3.2's response, and of course
Claude was favoring its little sister
and being like, "Yeah, um I think I
think that uh
you know, I don't think your
interpretation of what Jenna said is
accurate because you said she was being
angsty and uh she was actually being
cross." It was that sort of thing. And
this is why it's important to crack them
open.
Now, as for rough consistency and
length, those actually could be handled
inside the harness and post-processing.
So, making sure that it's, you know, got
the right number of references in the
thread, that's something very simple to
look at. You can just see how long the
thread is. And if there are more refs
than there are members of the thread,
that's incorrect uh when it comes to,
you know, how long the actual uh summary
is. If it's too long, you can just
truncate it.
And so, when we added the
post-processing,
we're actually able to close that gap
pretty solidly. Now, we've got uh 100%
JSON validity, structural validity was
100%, factual consistency, there's only
a little bit of a disagreement there,
and it turns out that it was the judge
being too darn strict.
>> [sighs and gasps]
>> We got the P5 uh P50 latency down to
around a
1 second, and P95 uh it was under 300
and
uh three three
three three and a half seconds. So,
that's pretty good. It actually ended up
meeting and beating Claude's on it after
doing this little bit of extra effort,
and I'm saving about a dollar a day in
inference costs.
So, the important thing is, after you've
done something like this, you don't want
to lose one ground. You'll want to make
sure that uh
you can update the prompt in the future
or upgrade the model.
You don't want to lose one ground. You
want to ensure that you can upgrade the
the model or change the prompt in the
future, and it won't cause summaries to
expand to be a paragraph long or
to start hallucinating things that are
untrue. You want to keep your evals
running for that, and that would be a
regression eval, and you run these sort
of like you run um CICD tests, you know,
uh it's how you keep your CTO from
blowing away your agentic experience by
accident one morning. True story,
happened to a founder friend of mine.
So, where do you get started?
Uh how many Claude calls could be Llama
calls? I I challenge you to go home
today and take a look at what you're
sending to LLM's and ask yourself, is
this something that a smaller model
could handle and how much money would I
save if I did that?
When working on AI projects, keep an eye
out for SLM's and specialized models
that might be on device already. For
instance, Chrome and the prompt API,
they access Gemini Nano which ships with
Chrome um natively and that can be
really useful cuz that means you don't
need to be shipping a model to anyone
using the browser. You can take
advantage of what's right there.
Keep in mind that these models are more
efficient and they meet your users where
they are. Their information stays on
device. You don't have to worry about
PII and you know, the energy consumption
is
well,
a blessing for the environment so to
speak.
Remember to prototype big
and deploy small.
You may want to prototype your system
with a foundation model and then convert
it parts of it to small language models
and specialized models for production.
Keep in mind you want to prove it,
define it, test it and then select your
sage model that passes the test.
You can use prompt engineering to help
get better results from SLM's and close
that gap with remote models.
So,
I challenge you to consider your current
implementation of prototype and convert
one feature to use a smaller local
model. Go home, try it out for yourself
and you might be surprised.
Anyway, I look forward to see you out
there on the web. If you enjoyed talking
about small local models or the
attentive web, you can follow me. I'm at
nearestneighbors.com.
If you want to try running some evals
with your current setup, you can start
testing with Phoenix at
phoenix.arise.com.
And lastly,
you can sign up for
uh the beta for Mima uh at mima.social.
I've been Rachel Neighbors, and it's
been awesome chatting with you today. Go
forth and build your own inference
stack.